I am a lover of language I use language
to tile reality to clothe reality in
description and prose I language
therefore I become I believe the world
is made of words and if you know the
words the world is made of you can make
of it whatever you wish one of the
coolest notions I've ever come across
about the trans formative and
transporting power of language is the
notion that words are not just
descriptive that words in fact are
generative
hold that in mind for a moment my friend
that the use of language the words you
use to describe reality can in fact
engender reality can disclose reality
words are generative and so people often
ask me how do you memorize
why do you memorize so many quotes cuz I
do man they are the wallpaper of my mind
is full of prose and and I don't know by
what act I actually put them into memory
but I can tell you that the reason that
I love to recite quotes is because I
believe that the quotes that resonate
the ones that give me goosebumps the one
that make the hairs on the back of my
neck stand up our intent ations they are
spells right there's a dream weaving and
a sorcery that is employed that is
deployed through language to speak is to
enact an indentation right so my
favorite quotes are these magical
incantations and as I recite therefore I
become I recite therefore I become that
makes perfect sense right this ecstatic
articulation and empowered vocalization
makes us what Walter Benjamin calls
enraptured prose beings
raised to the highest order we create
and perceive our world through language
we think reality into existence through
linguistic construction in real time we
are made of language and this concept is
instantiated even in our biology DNA is
code we are alphabetic all the way down
our genes are software programs even the
material world is made but of atoms
programmed into certain instantiation
McKenna was right the world is made of
words and if you know the words the
world is made of you can make of it
whatever you wish to take responsibility
for this metaphysical tool employ
language with discernment and intention
and agency and become an author of
reality
you